well as you know if you've been
following the story at all the FBI
hasn't been in possession of Hunter
Biden's laptop for years now even if
they as they've arrested over a thousand
and a thousand more to go people who
walk through the capitol on January 6
but in the case of the president's son
they've done nothing with it at all no
indictments even though as you also know
there is evidence of felonies on that
laptop so what is this about well it's
possible the FBI is working with Hunter
Biden the New York Post now reporting
that Hunter Biden had an FBI mole called
one eye
and this mole tipped off Hunter Biden's
Chinese business partners that they were
under investigation that is according to
an Israeli energy expert who was
arrested last month in Cyprus
on gun running charges and it looks like
he may be innocent we don't know Miranda
Devine is on this story as it develops
she joins us tonight so those are the
out ones and I apologize I apologize if
I've misstated them but you just kind of
sum this up this is an amazing story it
seems like
look Tucker It's actually bizarre
bizarre I mean it's an another bizarre
Twist on an already bizarre story about
the Biden family and the cast of
characters involved in their influence
peddling scheme around the world and Dr
gal loft is the latest one he is an
Israeli energy expert a professor he was
arrested in Cyprus as you said and is
still in a Cypress jail he's charged
apparently with gun running and thorough
violations and various things and he
claims that he is innocent and that he's
only been arrested to shut him up about
what he knows about the Biden family
business and you know a lot of his story
does check out he is regarded in his
orbit in Washington D.C as uh you know
he's well regarded he's a legitimate
energy expert he's a former high-ranking
officer in the Israeli Defense Force he
has multiple degrees and he also talks
about this FBI mole that he claims
Hunter Biden used to tip off his Chinese
partners that there was an FBI
investigation into them and there is
some corroboration of that from the
reporting that we've already done from
the laptop we know that Hunter Biden did
have contacts within the FBI we know
that he used them to benefit at least
one of his Chinese business partners
Patrick ho and when Patrick ho was
arrested at JFK by the FBI Hunter Biden
then contacted his FBI contacts and we
don't know what they did for him but
that sort of Accords with this story
that's coming from gal Loft and gal Loft
worked for three years in Washington DC
with Hunter Biden's Chinese business
partners that checks out too so he when
he says that those business partners
told him about what the Biden up to the
hundreds of thousands of dollars that he
knew about that was going to Hunter and
his Uncle Jim Biden every month and
their contact with this FBI mole it it
does uh it just bolsters I guess the
reporting we've done from the laptop
so quickly this left guy the Israeli
energy expert as he was being arrested
he tweeted and said they're arresting me
to shut me up I have the facts about
Hunter Biden he's a smart guy his social
media is still up if you want to see it
it confirms he's a very smart person has
he had anything else to say from his
jail in Cyprus do we know
look through his lawyer which is the
only way I've been able to talk to him
um he certainly has other allegations
but without documents or other evidence
to back it up um you know it's difficult
to report those he did get bail from the
cypriot courts a couple of weeks ago but
that has been vigorously opposed by U.S
authorities and I'm told by gal luft's
lawyer that The Ambassador in Cyprus is
putting a lot of pressure to keep him in
jail they want to extradite him to the
US on these charges of gun running and
so on which really baffle the people in
Washington who've known Gala for a long
time and they say that's not really in
his nature
well he doesn't have the profile of a
gun Runner that it might be worth a trip
to Cyprus oh no either Miranda Divine
thank you very much
thanks Tucker subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight